well as you know millions of people  started working from home when the  coronavirus forced office buildings to  shut down earlier this year  and it looks like that trend will  continue even after the pandemic is over  in a recent survey 87 percent of remote  workers  say they want the option to keep working  from home several major corporations are  now offering many employees the ability  to do their job at home permanently  zillow chief people officer dan spalding  says even with remote work  the company is keeping offices we  believe that even if people are working  from home  it's going to be important that they  have our offices to come together  collaborate talk through issues there's  a new study out from staffing agency  robert half  it found 61 percent of companies are  advertising fully remote jobs  and 60 percent are now expanding their  search geographically  to access a wider pool of candidates we